we mentioned the Miami Dolphins earlier
as relates to the possibility that they
will pursue Tom Brady they have landed
some big fish the aquatic mammals have
in Miami and they've gotten Kyle van Noy
away from the Patriots they have added
Byron Jones the Cowboys cornerback the
richest cornerback contract in NFL
history to go along with xavie and
Howard at number two they're on the same
team now and they added Erick flowers
yesterday as well so the Dolphins doing
what they can to spend their cap dollars
in advance of using their draft picks to
try to make the team better and though
the blood is in the water whether it's
the bills trying to improve or the
Dolphins trying to improve the Patriots
aren't going to have Tom Brady so the
window is open for someone to take over
the AFC East ya know it is that's there
to be had and you know I mean impressive
start to free agency you know they need
an improvement on their offensive line
get our Eric flowers not to any huge
money Eric flowers hey he kind of
corrected his career when he went to the
Washington Redskins and gotten going
there so that was a nice signing there
but then you can see Flores is trying to
emulate what he had in New England
before he left you know I kind of said
this on social media yesterday he's
recreating Stephon Gilmore and JC
Jackson who are arguably the best duo in
football they're gonna have a challenge
now whether it'll be the best duo in
their own division because for me Byron
Jones Xavier Howard are two of the top
five or six best corners in football
fireman Jones when he's healthy you
could make a case when you watch him on
film Mike and go oh he's the most
talented guy in the sport at the corner
position so yeah then Kyle van Noy as we
know he's a Swiss Army knife as far as
the things you can do with him in the
front seven so great start for free
agency for the paint I mean enough for
the Miami Dolphins you know got some
culture guys and got some guys that are
certainly going to improve the football
team I'll tell you what if I'm throwing
a dart here and I may be blindfolded and
there may not even be a dart board but
what without the 49ers interested in Tom
Brady there really isn't a place that
screams out he will win there right away
right and III we cannot overlook the
Giselle factor
she's dealt with all these years of Tom
playing for the Patriots and continuing
to play well past the retirement age for
most football players when she married
him she probably figured by the time
this guy's 42 he won't be playing
anymore if she says I want to go to
Miami that's going to be a factor and I
think he could convince himself that
they can be competitive at least as
competitive as the Buccaneers as
competitive as the Chargers and unless
there's a team that has that clear-cut
Super Bowl window and other than the
49ers again who don't want him there's
no other team that it would even have
the the glimmer of an opening that has
realistic Super Bowl aspirations I just
I feel like Nigeria dolphins are a
legitimate spot for Tom Brady yeah III
hear ya I mean there's a lot to like and
of course he's gonna be comfortable with
brought Brian Flores and to what we
talked about you know a little earlier
where I said you know I think there was
a sense of some coaches are a little
scared of Brady of course that won't
happen with Brian Flores I mean he's
running things just like New England and
you know Chris Greer I've heard nothing
but good things about him so it
certainly won't be a culture shock if
Brady goes there and the lifestyle in
the city to your point Mike all makes
sense it's just about whether Brady
would want to deal you know with one
year here kind of them continuing to get
their feet underneath them as they build
a a real winner here which I think
they're going to build they're going in
the right direction I just I don't know
in my heart of hearts I just don't know
if Tom Brady would sign up for that
right now
and and let's apply a small twist to
what we were saying yesterday and
previously if there's not gonna be an
offseason program it makes sense for
Brady to want to stay with the Patriots
it also made sense for the Patriots to
want Brady but that didn't work out but
if he's gonna leave he needs to go to a
place where he knows that when he shows
up it's going to be like the Patriots
right so the Dolphins are at the top of
that list you don't know what you're
getting into with Bruce Arians you don't
know what you're getting into with
Anthony Lynn there's just a few places
where you would have confidence that
when you walk through the door there's
going to be an expectation level that
the Patriots always had and that's
Detroit and that's Miami and we're
else am I missing anyone you probably
Houston yeah and because I got the Shawn
Watson right so no I and and and the
lions are all in with Matthew Stafford
they're not making that trade although I
don't want to get down that rabbit hole
again I think the Lions are keeping
Matthew Stafford I just think the
Dolphins makes sense for Tom Brady
especially when the alternative short
term is Ryan Fitzpatrick and they have
enough draft picks that they can load up
the cannon to win now and also draft a
guy who can be groomed by Brady and if
Brady's only gonna be there three years
maximum he's not gonna be threatened by
the guy like he was threatened by
Garoppolo I just think it makes too much
sense I feel like yeah my pot my pasta
and meatballs got is starting to he's
starting to respond well to this
scenario Chris okay there's a lot of
things to connect there I think okay if
I just have to go with my you know I
don't know I don't get pasta and
meatballs cuz I got no Italian and my
good okay so I gotta go with my meat and
potatoes got over here okay I got a lot
of chicken soup in my gut
I'm gonna say the chargers of the team
if I had to pick one right now that I
say he ends up that and I have no inside
information or that but I'm just gonna
gut feeling like you would you rather
have Cam Newton or Tom Brady for the
Chargers oh man man you love putting me
on the spot but I think I you know of
course we're assuming medicals check out
what his hand knew and everything like
that I would rather have Cam Newton at
this point I would you know it's just
again Brady at this age I worry about
injury I worry about his ability to want
to stand in the pocket make big throws
and you know I you know I just worry
about you know injury and in general him
pulling a hamstring or you know pulling
a calf muscle can change your team and
you could be back in the same boat
you're in right now next year if he
decides he wants to call it quits so
that's why I would favor Cam Newton yeah
and and look Cam Newton's gonna want a
new contract he's made that clear
already like in 19 million it's it's
embarrassing in comparison to the
current market but that's gonna be a
fact
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports